SALMAN KHAN: The Khan
Academy is most known
for its collection of videos.
So before I go any
farther, let me
show you a little
bit of a montage.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So the hypotenuse is
now going to be five.
This animal's fossils
are only found
in this area of South
America, nice, clean band
here, and in this
part of Africa.
We could integrate
over the surface,
and the notation usually
is a capital sigma.
National Assembly, they
create the committee
of public safety, which sounds
like a very nice committee.
Notice this is an aldehyde,
and it's an alcohol.
Start differentiating into
effector and memory cells.
A galaxy, hey, there's
another galaxy.
Oh look, there's another galaxy.
And for dollars is their 30
million plus the $20 million
from the American manufacturer.
If this does not blow your
mind, then you have no emotion.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SALMAN KHAN: We now have on
the order of 2,200 videos
covering everything from
basic arithmetic all
the way to vector calculus
and some of the stuff
that you saw up there.
We have a million students
a month using the site,
watching on the order of
100,000 to 200,000 videos a day.
But what we're going
to talk about in this
is how we're going
to the next level.
But before I do that, I want
to talk a little bit about how
I got started.
And some of you all might
know, about five years ago,
I was an analyst
at a hedge fund.
And I was in Boston.
And I was tutoring my cousins
in New Orleans remotely.
And I started putting the first
YouTube videos up, really just
as a nice to have, just kind of
a supplement, for my cousins,
something that might give them
a refresher, or something.
And as soon as I put those
first YouTube videos up,
something interesting happened.
Actually, a bunch of
interesting things happened.
The first was the
feedback from my cousins.
They told me that they preferred
me on YouTube than in person.
[LAUGHTER]
And once you get over the
backhanded nature of that,
there was actually something
very profound there.
They were saying that they
preferred the automated version
of their cousin to their cousin.
At first it's very unintuitive,
but when you actually
think about it from
their point of view,
it makes a ton of sense.
You have this situation where
now they can pause and repeat
their cousin without feeling
like they're wasting my time.
If they have to review something
that they should have learned
a couple of weeks ago, or
maybe a couple of years ago,
they don't have to be
embarrassed and ask
their cousin.
They can just
watch those videos.
If they're bored,
they can go ahead.
They can watch it at their
own time, at their own pace.
And probably the least
appreciated aspect of this
is the notion that the very
first time, the very first time
that you're trying to get your
brain around a new concept,
the very last thing you need
is another human being saying
do you understand this.
And that's what was happening
with the interaction
with my cousins before.
And now they could just do it in
the intimacy of their own room.
The other thing that happened
is I put them on YouTube
just for the-- I saw no
reason to make it private.
So I let other people watch it.
And then people started
stumbling on it.
And I started getting some
comments, and some letters,
and all sorts of feedback from
random people around the world.
And these are just a few.
This is actually from one of
the original calculus videos.
And someone wrote on YouTube,
it was a YouTube comment,
"First time I smiled
doing a derivative."
Let's pause here.
This person did a derivative,
and then they smiled.
And then in response
to that same comment,
this is on the thread.
You could go on YouTube
and look at these comments.
Someone else wrote,
"Same thing here.
I actually got a natural
high and a good mood
for the entire day,
since I remember
seeing all of this
'matrix text' in class.
And here I'm all
like, I know Kung Fu."
[LAUGHTER]
And we got a lot of
feedback along those lines.
This clearly was helping people.
But then, as the viewership
kept growing, and kept growing,
I started getting
letters from people.
And it was starting
to become clear
that it was actually more
than just a nice to have.
This is just an excerpt
from one of those letters.
"My 12-year-old son
has autism, and has
had a terrible time with math.
We have tried everything, viewed
everything, bought everything.
We stumbled on your video on
decimals, and it got through.
Then we went on to
the dreaded fractions.
Again, he got it.
We could not believe it.
He is so excited."
And so you can
imagine, here I was,
an analyst at a hedge fund.
It was very strange for me to
do something of social value.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
But I was excited.
So I kept going.
And then a few other things
started to dawn on me.
That not only would it
help my cousins right now,
or these people who
were sending letters.
But maybe that this
content will never go old.
That it could help their
kids or their grandkids.
If Isaac Newton had done
YouTube videos on calculus,
I wouldn't have to,
assuming he was good.
We don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
The other thing that happened,
and even at this point, I said,
OK, maybe it's a
good supplement.
It's good for
motivated students.
It's good for maybe
homeschoolers.
But I didn't think it would be
something that would somehow
penetrate the classroom.
But then I started getting
letters from teachers.
And the teachers
would write saying,
we've used your videos
to flip the classroom.
You've given the lectures.
So now what we do--
and this could actually
happen in every classroom in
America tomorrow-- what I do
is I assign the
lectures for homework.
And what used to
be homework, I now
have the students
doing in the classroom.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to pause
here for a second
because there's a couple
of interesting things.
One, when those
teachers are doing that,
there's the obvious benefit.
There's the benefit
that now their students
can enjoy the videos in the
way that my cousins did.
They can pause, repeat at their
own pace, at their own time.
But the more interesting
thing-- and this
is the unintuitive thing when
you talk about technology
in the classroom-- by removing
the "one size fits all"
lecture from the classroom
and letting students have
a self-paced lecture
at home, and then when
you go to the classroom,
letting them do work,
having the teacher walk around,
having the peers actually
be able to interact
with each other,
these teachers have
used technology
to humanize the classroom.
They took a fundamentally
dehumanizing experience,
a bunch of 30 kids with
their fingers on their lips,
not allowed to interact
with each other.
A teacher, no
matter how good, has
to give this kind of
"one size fits all"
lecture to 30 students-- blank
faces, slightly antagonistic.
And now it's a human experience.
Now they're actually
interacting with each other.
So once the Khan
Academy-- I quit my job.
And we turned into
a real organization,
or a not-for-profit.
The question is, how do we
take this to the next level?
How do we take what
those teachers were
doing to their
natural conclusion?
And so what I'm
showing over here,
these are actual
exercises that I
started writing for my cousins.
The ones I started were
much more primitive.
This is a more
competent version of it.
But the paradigm here is we'll
generate as many questions
as you need until
you get that concept,
until you get 10 in a row.
And the Khan Academy
videos are there.
You get hints, the actual
steps for that problem,
if you don't know how to do it.
But the paradigm, it seems
like a very simple thing.
10 in a row, you move on.
But it's fundamentally
different than what's
happening in
classrooms right now.
In a traditional
classroom, you have
a couple of-- homework,
lecture, homework, lecture,
and then you have
a snapshot exam.
And that exam, whether you get
a 70%, an 80%, a 90% or a 95%,
the class moves on
to the next topic.
And even that 95% student, what
was the 5% they didn't know?
Maybe they didn't
know what happens
when you raise something
to the 0-th power.
And then you go build on
that in the next concept.
That's analogous to-- imagine
learning to ride a bicycle.
And I give you a bicycle.
Maybe I give you a
lecture ahead of time.
And I give you that
bicycle for two weeks.
And then I come back
after two weeks.
And I say, well, let's see.
You're having trouble
taking left turns.
You can't quite stop.
You're an 80% bicyclist.
So I put a big C stamp
on your forehead.
And then I say
here's a unicycle.
But as ridiculous
as that sounds,
that's exactly what's happening
in our classrooms right now.
And the idea is
you fast forward.
And good students start failing
algebra all of a sudden,
and start failing
calculus all of a sudden,
despite being smart, despite
having good teachers.
And it's usually because
they had these Swiss cheese
gaps that kept building
throughout their foundations.
So our model is learn math the
way you would learn anything.
Like the way you
would learn a bicycle.
Stay on that bicycle.
Fall off that bicycle.
Do it as long as necessary
until you have mastery.
The traditional model,
it penalizes you
for experimentation and failure.
But it does not expect mastery.
We encourage you to experiment.
We encourage you to failure.
But we do expect mastery.
This is just another
one of the modules.
This is trigonometry.
This is shifting and
reflecting functions.
And they all fit together.
We have about 90
of these right now.
And you could go to
the site right now.
It's all free.
Not trying to sell anything.
But the general idea
is that they all
fit into this knowledge map.
That top node
right there, that's
literally single-digit addition.
It's like 1 plus
1 is equal to 2.
And the paradigm is, once
you get 10 in a row on that,
then it keeps forwarding you to
more and more advanced modules.
So keep-- this is further
down the knowledge map.
We're getting into more
advanced arithmetic.
Further down, you
start getting into
pre-algebra and early algebra.
Further down, you start getting
into algebra one, algebra two,
a little bit of precalculus.
And the idea is, from this, we
can actually teach everything.
Well, everything
that can be taught
in this type of a framework.
So you can imagine.
And this is what
we are working on--
is from this knowledge
map, you have logic.
You have computer programming.
You have grammar.
You have genetics.
All based off of that core of,
OK, If you know this and that,
now you're ready for
this next concept.
Now that can work well
for an individual learner.
And I encourage one, for
you to do with your kids.
But I also encourage everyone in
the audience to do it yourself.
It'll change what happens
at the dinner table.
But what we want to do is
use the natural conclusion
of the flipping of the classroom
that those early teachers
had emailed me about.
And so what I'm
showing you here,
this is actually data from a
pilot in the Los Altos school
district, where they took two
fifth-grade classes, and two
seventh-grade classes,
and completely gutted
their old math curriculum.
These kids aren't
using textbooks.
They're not getting "one
size fits all" lectures.
They're doing Khan Academy.
They're doing that
software for roughly half
of their math class.
And I want to make it clear.
We don't view this as a
complete math education.
What it does is--
and this is what's
happening Los Altos--
it frees up time.
This is the blocking
and tackling.
Making sure you know how to
do the system of equations.
And it frees up time for the
simulations, for the games,
for the mechanics, for
the robot building,
for the estimating how high that
hill is based on its shadow.
And so the paradigm is the
teacher walks in every day.
Every kid works
at their own pace.
And a teacher-- this is actually
a live dashboard from Los Altos
school district-- and they
look at this dashboard.
Every row is a student.
Every column is one
of those concepts.
Green means the student's
already proficient.
Blue means that they're working
on it, no need to worry.
Red means they're stuck.
And what the teacher does
is literally just says,
let me intervene
on the red kids.
Or even better, let me get
one of the green kids who
are already proficient
in that concept
to be the first line of attack
and actually tutor their peer.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I come from a very
data-centric reality.
So we don't want that teacher to
even go and intervene and have
to ask the kid
awkward questions.
Oh, what do you not understand,
or what do you understand,
and all of the rest.
So our paradigm is to
really arm the teachers
with as much data as possible.
Really data that, in almost
any other field, is expected.
If you're in finance, or
marketing, or manufacturing.
And so the teachers
can actually diagnose
what's wrong with the
students, so that they
can make their interaction
as productive as possible.
So now the teachers
know exactly what
the student's been up
to, how long they've
been spending every day.
What videos have
they been watching?
When did they pause the videos?
What did they stop watching?
What exercises are they using?
What have they been focused on?
The outer circle shows the
exercises they were focused on.
The inner circle shows the
videos they're focused on.
And the data gets
pretty granular.
So you can actually
see the exact problems
that the student
got right or wrong.
Red is wrong.
Blue is right.
The leftmost question
is the first question
that the student attempted.
They watched the video
right over there.
And then you could
see eventually they
were able to get 10 in a row.
It's almost like
you can almost see
them learning over
those last 10 problems.
They also got faster.
The height is how
long it took them.
So when you talk about
self-paced learning,
it makes sense for everyone--
in education speak,
differentiated learning.
But it's kind of crazy what
happens when you actually
see it in a classroom.
Because every time
we've done this,
in every classroom we've done,
over and over again, if you
go five days into
it, there's a group
of kids who have raced ahead.
And there's a group of kids
who are a little bit slower.
And in a traditional model, if
you did a snapshot assessment,
you say, oh, these
are the gifted kids.
These are the slow kids.
Maybe they should be
tracked differently.
Maybe we should put them
in different classes.
But when you let every student
work at their own pace,
and we see it over and
over and over again.
You see students who took
a little bit extra time
on one concept or the other.
But once they get through that
concept, they just race ahead.
And so the same kids
that you thought
were slow six weeks ago, you
now would think are gifted.
And we're seeing it over
and over and over again.
And it makes you
really wonder how much
all of the labels a lot
of us have benefited from
were really just due to
a coincidence of time.
Now, as valuable as
something like this
is in a district like
Los Altos, our goal
is to use technology
to humanize,
not just in Los Altos, but kind
of on a global scale, what's
happening in education.
And actually that brings
an interesting point.
A lot of the effort in
humanizing the classroom
is focused on student
to teacher ratios.
In our mind the
relevant metric is
"student to valuable human
time with the teacher" ratio.
So in a traditional model,
most of the teacher's time
is spent doing lectures, and
grading tests, and whatnot.
Maybe 5% of their
time is actually
sitting next to students and
actually working with them.
Now 100% of their time is.
So once again, using
technology, not just
flipping the classroom, you're
humanizing the classroom,
I'd argue, by a
factor of five or 10.
And as valuable as
it is in Los Altos,
imagine what that does to
the adult learner who's
embarrassed to go back and learn
stuff that they should have
known before, before
going back to college.
Imagine what it does to a
street kid in Calcutta who
has to help his
family during the day.
And that's the reason why he
or she can't go to school.
Now they can spend
two hours a day
and remediate or get
up to speed and not
feel embarrassed about
what they do or don't know.
Now imagine what happens where--
we talked about the peers
teaching each other
inside of a classroom.
But this is all one system.
There's no reason why
you can't have that peer
to peer tutoring beyond
that one classroom.
Imagine what happens if
that student in Calcutta
all of a sudden
can tutor your son.
Or your son can tutor
that kid in Calcutta.
And I think what
you'll see emerging
is this notion of a global
one world classroom.
And that's essentially
what we're trying to build.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
BILL GATES: I've
seen some things
you're doing in the system
that have to do with motivation
and feedback-- energy
points, merit badges.
Tell me what you're
thinking there.
SALMAN KHAN: Oh yeah, no,
we have an awesome team
working on that.
And I have to be clear.
It's not just me anymore.
I'm still doing all the videos.
We have a rock star
team doing the software.
Yeah, we've put a
bunch of game mechanics
in there, where you
get these badges.
We're going to start having
leader boards by areas,
and you get points.
It's actually been
pretty interesting.
Just the wording of the
badging, or how many points you
get for doing something, we
see on the system-wide basis
tens of thousands
of fifth graders
or sixth graders going one
direction or another, depending
on what badge you give them.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL GATES: And the
collaboration you're
doing with Los Altos,
how did that come about?
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah, Los
Altos was kind of crazy.
Once again, I didn't expect
it to be used in classrooms.
Someone from their board
came and said, what would you
do if you had carte
blanche in a classroom?
And I said, well, I would
just-- every student
work at their own pace
on something like this.
We'd give a dashboard.
And they said, oh, this
is kind of radical,
we have to think about it.
And me and the rest of team
were like, they're never
going to want to do this.
But literally the next
day they were like,
can you start in two weeks?
[LAUGHTER]
BILL GATES: So it's
fifth-grade math
is where that's
going on right now?
SALMAN KHAN: It's two
fifth-grade classes
and two seventh-grade classes.
They're doing it at
the district level.
And I think what
they're excited about
is they can now
follow these kids.
It's not an only
in-school thing.
Even on Christmas, we saw
some of the kids were doing.
And we track everything.
So they can actually
track them as they
go through the entire district,
through the summers, as they
go from one teacher to a next.
You have this continuity of
data that, even at the district
level, they can see.
BILL GATES: So
some of those views
we saw were for the teacher
to go in and track actually
what's going on with those kids.
So you're getting feedback
on those teacher views
to see what they
think they need?
SALMAN KHAN: Oh yeah.
Actually, most of those
were specs by the teachers.
We made some of
those for students
so they could their data.
But we have a very
tight design loop
with the teachers themselves.
And they're literally
saying, hey, this is nice.
But that focus graph,
a lot of the teachers
said I have a feeling that a lot
of the kids are jumping around,
and not focusing on one topic.
So we made that focus
diagram for them.
So it's all been teacher driven.
It's been pretty crazy.
BILL GATES: Is this
ready for prime time?
Do you think a lot of
classes next school
year should try this thing out?
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah.
It's ready.
We've got a million people
on the site already.
So we can handle a few more.
And no, no reason
why it really can't
happen in every classroom
in America tomorrow.
BILL GATES: And the vision
of the tutoring thing.
The idea there is, if I'm
confused about a topic,
somehow right in
the user interface,
I'd find people who
are volunteering,
maybe see their reputation.
And I could schedule and
connect up with those people.
SALMAN KHAN: Absolutely.
And this is something
I recommend everyone
in this audience to do.
Those dashboards the teachers
have, you can go log in right
now.
And you could essentially
become a coach
for your kids, your nephews,
your cousins, or maybe
some kids at the
Boys & Girls Club.
And you can start becoming
a mentor or tutor really
immediately.
But yeah, it's all there.
BILL GATES: Well, it's amazing.
I think you've
just got a glimpse
of the future of education.
Thank you.
SALMAN KHAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]